the three most important steps to
starting a new business I get asked a
lot by entrepreneurs who have an idea
and they're trying to figure out how do
I launch this thing how do I get
customers how do I what are the steps
that I need to take to get this thing
off the ground a great one came in
recently from one of our youtube viewers
love you guys Celeste grow it into say I
have an idea I want to create a magazine
what are the steps I need to take them
pursuing it here are the three steps
okay these are the three most important
steps you need to take when you're
starting up first identify your passion
if you want to have success in business
you have to be passionate about your
business you have to love what you do
every other rule in business does not
apply will not help you will not save
you will not let you build something
successful unless you love your business
okay so Celestia wants to start a
magazine that better.because me because
she loves magazines or because she sees
a change as she can make in the world
have a positive impact that she needs to
lead this charge if she started the
magazine just because you can make money
at magazines it's not going to work it's
never going to take off you have to love
it so much you're willing to push
through every hurdle every barrier that
gets thrown in your way because the same
people the people who don't love it the
logical people will quit because it gets
too hard it's the crazy entrepreneurs
who love their business so much would do
it even if they weren't making money at
it who keep pushing through and you have
to push through so much crap to get to
the place of success so do you love this
business idea enough to persist with it
to keep going with it to eventually turn
it into something successful to deal
with tons and tons of crap because it's
going to be hard so that's number one
number two if you're trying to now I've
identified my passions those magazines
okay or whatever the business is for you
how do you go out and get this thing
started if you have no experience in
this business you're not going to get a
lot of money you're not going to get a
lot of new clients because you don't
know what you're doing you want to make
money as an entrepreneur you make money
by providing value
the more value provide the more money
you're going to make if you don't have
enough knowledge experience history to
provide great value you're not going to
make a lot of money you're going to make
tons of rookie mistakes you're going to
maybe take on debt try to build this
thing out and it doesn't work and you
end up going back and getting the job
and paying off this debt for the rest of
your life you got to get some experience
so go work for a company go work for a
small business who's in your field get
to know the industry see if it's for you
see if you still like this thing see if
you like me in a magazine producer or
not go work for a small magazine see how
they do it see how they make customers
see how they create content see how they
distribute their product see how they
market their business see how they run
their company determine is it for you or
not do you still love this thing or not
meanwhile you're getting paid to make
mistakes you're getting your education
and you're getting paid to get an
education and being an entrepreneur in
the magazine business then when you're
ready to start you keep your current job
and you start on the side start getting
one customer one customer if you're
doing a magazine try to talk to an
advertiser try to talk to content
producers try doing something on the
side to build it up meanwhile you're
gaining experience from your job you're
still seeing if you're passionate about
this business or not and on the side
you're starting this thing up try to get
one person to pay you for what you do
one person who's interested who will put
dollars on the table and give it to you
to start this thing and keep building it
up to the point where you have enough
money to quit your job because most
entrepreneurs quit their jobs start up a
company run out of cash you have to go
back and get a job you don't let time
for momentum to build so start part-time
start on the side using your current job
you're learning the industry you're
getting connections and experience and
you tap into those to create your first
business and find your first customer
and you build your business around your
customer because what you thought your
business is going to be it never is it
always changes your great idea to start
is never how it actually works out
you have to talk to customers and react
to the market and that will lead you to
the path of success it's so critically
important because most entrepreneurs get
this wrong most entrepreneurs fail right
80% of companies fail that's going to be
you likely right now you're watching
these videos you're investing in
yourself you are learning to be a better
entrepreneur so that increases your
chances but if you are just getting
started
and you don't know what business you
want to start how to go about doing it
follow those key steps 1 make sure you
are passion make sure you are following
something that you absolutely love doing
to go get a job to learn about it learn
from someone who's gone through it and
can help be a mentor for you and then 3
start your business on the side get your
first customer and prove that what you
have will work and expand from there
those are your starting steps that's
your homework if you have questions
write to me I'm happy to walk you
through even more detailed if you need
it but that's how you start a successful
business belief fuels your watching if
you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below it always works you want
to do more and I'd love to hear what you
have to think please leave a comment
below
seeing those comments coming in fuel me
to make more videos to answer your
questions I love them come in thank you
so much and I'll see you soon